hi everyone it's joanna here welcome to
another home workout how are you coping
i hope that you are still staying active
with my videos so today's workout is a
total body strength training workout
but the thing is that you won't need any
equipment at all so you can do this at
home in a very small space so what we're
doing is that we're using your body your
own body as resistance so there will be
a total of eight exercises okay we want
to be counting down the first set the
goal is to complete 20 reps and then
going down to 15 reps 10 reps and 5 reps
let's start with a quick warm-up let's
start by standing shoulder width apart
with your toes pointer forward and let's
get into a nice deep squat and a reverse
lunge so alternating between legs left
and right good squat down
and push it back
nice there you go
keep going
reverse lunge
squat down
and back
good try to drive your knee closer to
the ground okay and just relax your
upper body
last one more
down
back
on the other side squat down
and back
good now what i want to do is just tap
side to side okay
just again warming up our body and just
opening up
your chest
and your back muscles as well okay so
tap side to side and feel
the stretch on your upper body
keep going
a few more
tap
tap
tap and tap
good okay now step right at the edge of
your mat let's get down into inchworm
into a plank
give me one push-up
and back up
all right
if you can try to keep your legs
straight throughout the entire movement
and you will feel the stretch on your
hamstrings up
back down give me two more
into a
push-up back up
straight last one more
down
into a push-up
and
back
up
all right now let's stretch our hip
flexor out a little bit okay so what i'm
going to do is come down get into a high
plank
take your right leg forward and just
open up
back into a high plank
and now on the left side
reach your arms
straight up to the ceiling good
the other side open up
back into a high plank
stretch it out
last few more
give me two more
okay right side
last final set
left
stretch it out and
slowly
inch yourself back up
okay
do you feel your body warmed up we're
going to start with the first round okay
for the first one it's going to be 20
repetitions so we're going to start with
our lower body the first workout is
going to be a lateral square walk so the
goal here is to stay in a low squat
position throughout so stand shoulder
width apart with your toes pointed
forward stay start in a low squat and
walk left to right okay
ready
let's go start low
left to right is one
good and that's two
what i would say is place both arms just
by the side of your head
this way you will make sure that you're
keeping your chest up
and stay low
seven
good
go wider eight
nice
feel the squeeze on your thighs your
glutes every part of your legs should be
working
and stay low give me eight more one
two
go wider okay three
four
five
chest up
and stay low three more one
two
last one more three
good okay the first set the first rock
is going to be the most challenging
round and i promise you it would get
easier after this that's what she says
all right second lower body workout
lunge to curtsy okay if you have done my
live workout last two weeks you will
know this workout it's a killer so step
back into a lunge position
and then cross into a curtsy all right
that is
one so we're going for 20. so just
working on our right side to begin with
step right at the front of your mat
ready let's go step back lunge drive
your knee as low as you can towards the
floor two
with strength training workout you don't
have to rush through the workout really
slow the pace down
engage
your muscles okay it's about the mind
and body connection
feel the work and the tension on your
legs and your glutes
seven
don't worry i'm counting eight
nine go low
ten
okay if you need to you can come back up
for a while take three breaths and get
back down for another ten more one
good
two halfway there
three look straight ahead
push down
four
so as you get into a curtsy it will work
more on
your glutes and your outer thighs oh i
can already feel the burn
last four more
let's go three more
three
last two
one more
one
cross and ah oh my gosh
shake
your legs out okay we have worked on our
right side now
let's not forget our left leg alright so
start right in front of your mat take a
right step back
down
and cross okay
very good back down
and cross
look straight ahead
breathe out as you come up
six nice
seven if at all
you feel like you need to take a short
break
come back up
take two deep breaths
and
get back down okay so we're halfway
there get back up breathe in breathe out
shake it out a little bit let's get back
down and finish the remaining ten
take a white lunge
two
three
good
four
i can feel your burn five
go low six
ah stay with me seven
eight
nine
last one more
10
and back up
you are going to get a short break for
your lower body let's get down onto the
mat
and work on our upper body the next
workout is going to be a narrow to a
white push-up okay
so the narrow push-up is going to work
on your triceps and the white push-up
will work on your chest muscles
all right let's start with a narrow
push-up
yourself down
push your elbow back
get into a white push-up
down
and push yourself back up
okay so nice and easy
down
and one that is four if you want more
challenge what you can do is explode
jump out and in
good
and out and in halfway there
really making sure that both elbows are
pointed back when you're in a narrow
push-up position
good six more
down
up
four more push it back
last two more okay
narrow go as low as you can and explode
go low and push yourself up
all right
still working on our upper body focusing
on your back muscles as well as your
core and your shoulders let's get down
into
a supernatural superman squeeze and a
plank so lie on your belly
keep your legs straight and flat onto
the ground spread them apart a little
bit
what i'm going to do is
get into a superman position squeeze
your back muscles for two count place
both pumps next to your chest and push
yourself up in one straight line
remember
it's not peeling yourself off the floor
this is wrong
in a low position push yourself up tuck
your toes under straight up okay
challenge yourself let's go
superman up
squeeze
hands by your chest push up
and down
20 reps squeeze
tuck your toes and down if this is too
challenging what you can do is get up
onto your knees
and back down
okay choose your options squeeze
up to your knees and
down
very good remember hold the squeeze for
two counts and up
nice against gently onto the floor lift
your chest
off
leave your thighs off the floor squeeze
hold it
and push back up
good job guys keep going squeeze
push up
this is the first set
so you might still be getting used to
the movements but that is absolutely
fine
we have
three more sets to go halfway there
push up
give me ten more okay
squeeze pumps by your chest straight up
and remember straight back down
do not collapse
push up
back down
squeeze
straight up okay very good
six more
ah remember that
every time
you feel like giving up that's when you
should
give yourself that little bit of push
and because that's how you're going to
progress okay
lost three more
strong arms strong upper body strong
core
last one more
back down
squeeze every inch
squeeze
up
and
just shake it out okay
stretch a little bit if you need to
stretch it out
and come back up okay
next we want to work on our lower body
again so it's going to be a single leg
lunge this can be a little bit of a
challenge because it's going to work on
your balance as well so let's start on
our right leg okay what i'm going to do
is find that firm foundation
lift your left leg off the floor bend
your knee bend your right knee and tap
onto the floor as you come up squeeze
your glutes okay let's aim for 20
right ready let's go
down tap
and squeeze it right at the top
slow it down as you lower yourself
squeeze create more tension
lower down
and squeeze good
bring your body down
remember to keep your back flat all the
time so do not hunch okay looking
straight ahead
nice
squeeze
and engage your core suck your belly in
and squeeze if this is too challenging
what you can do is as lou as you come up
take a small tap
release
and
lower yourself back down
good 12 more
bend your knee tap gently and up
and up last 10 more
then
and up
good
all right don't rush through the workout
find one focal point and just look
at that point throughout
good
remember to breathe out
as you come up
last five more
squeeze
four more
up squeeze
just working on one side at a time
three
last two more
last one more
down and squeeze very good okay right
leg done
you know what's next left side okay
there is going to be a little bit more
challenge on your left leg especially
for me i struggle to find my balance on
this side alright let's go
again lift your right leg off
lower your body down tap
and come back up
okay the goal
is to find your balance as well
tighten your core because we want to
really strengthen our core the core is
the foundation to your body the stronger
your core is the stronger you will be
performing in all your other workouts
five
good
slowly down lower bend your knees
six
good
squeeze your glutes right at the top
squeeze
nice
12 more
very good
halfway there if you need to take a
short break tap
count to three and
lower yourself back down
okay halfway there
you have eight more wraps
slow it down bend your knee
breathe out
five more
whoo-hoo
down squeeze
oh all the work
just on one leg
last three
two more
so with all these exercises it is low
impact
but it is extremely effective in toning
up and sculpting your muscles okay done
okay
the next workout we still want to work
on our glutes okay so lie down onto the
mat
bring your hips up
into a bridge position but instead of
doing the normal bridge what i'm going
to do is
let both heels meet
inwards and then point your knees
outwards okay
place both palms down
and same thing lower your butt down
and squeeze it right at the top
this will activate your glutes even more
down
squeeze
back down
and up
remember
to hold it for at least one to two
counts right at the top
good
up
and down good imagine there's a string
pulling you through
right in the middle of your belly button
halfway there let's give me ten more
good
last eight squeeze keep going
don't stop right now
up last five more
one
let's count together two
three
and for the final rep i want to just
hold it right at the top and count one
two
three
four and five and lower it down okay
ah just shake your legs out a little bit
okay now gently come back up
short rest for your legs back to our
upper body
next is going to be a really interesting
push-up it's going to be dwarfing
push-ups again working on the strength
of your triceps
your shoulders as well as your core okay
so let's get into a low plank position
and what i'm going to do is pick your
butt up
and slowly lower yourself back down okay
making sure that both elbows are pointed
back ready let's go pike it up
and back down
push it up
and back down if this is too challenging
what you can do is start in a high plank
position and pike your butt up okay
this is an easier option if not get back
down and let's continue the workout pick
it up
do the work and your triceps and your
shoulders pick it up push it up
staying on your toes
and push it up very good
okay
keeping a strong and firm plank so do
not dip
or arch your back
and breathe out as you pike your butt
up
without
pushing your arms pushing your triceps
to help you give me 10 more
push it up
down
feel your arms shaking that is
absolutely fine feel your entire body
working
okay back down push it up
okay back down
push it up
down
last five more
back down you are strong
three
last two more
two stay with me one more
up and just
drop
okay
one final workout one final workout and
you will get a short break and that is
the end of the first round all right
let's get back down okay still in a low
plank position the final workout is
going to be a plank up down so push
yourself up
and down that's one okay
and we want to aim for
20
good
three
and four
avoid moving your hips too much so don't
dip your hip this is strong okay engage
your car
slowly drop your body down
and slowly lift it up alternating
between the arms
halfway there ten more
spread your fingers apart if you need to
that will give you a stronger base
last eight more
down
and up
yes it is more challenging for the first
round
stay strong stay with me last five more
up
last three
last two
one more
and
just
press it out
very well done
just
roll your arms
give
your arms a short break
oh
that is the end of the first
round
take a short break keep yourself
hydrated and we want to move on to the
second round
very well done
[Music]
all right let's move on to the second
set we want to repeat the entire circuit
again but this time 15 reps okay so
let's do this let's start in a low squat
position let's go left and right good
lateral squat walk
two
good
three very nice stay low four
five as wide as you can
six nice
it's all a low impact workout
but it's still very effective to build
your muscles and to maintain a lean
figure let's go ten more
one
two
three
four
last one okay i've forgotten it's only
15 reps
5 15. very good job all right now
lunch to curtsy okay so step right in
front let's go one lunge back
curtsy
just working on your right side two
good keeping a low lunge throughout
three
very good
four
stay low stay with me
ten more
seven
eight
nine
crossover
ten
last five more okay
one
two
three
last two more
four
last one more
five
and back up oh my gosh
my right thighs i can really feel the
burn okay
change side okay so now let's work on
our left thighs take a right step back
and cross making sure that your body is
squared
facing forward throughout the entire
workout
three
four
nice
five
keep going
six
if you need to you can come back up take
a short break and back down okay
and ten
okay we're not there yet okay five more
let's go one
two cross last three
three
feel the burn
four
last one more you've got this five
and ah
take a shot break
give your thighs
nice pad
and let's get back down onto the floor
for our upper upper body circuit okay
narrow to wide push-up okay only
15 times let's go narrow
that's two
three
four
nice
keep going six
nice really push your triceps back
and
work on your triceps eight
last five more one
wide
three
push it down drive your chest down push
your transit back and push yourself back
up
okay good now lie straight down onto the
floor okay
superman squeeze to plank
working on your back muscles your core
muscles and your glutes up squeeze one
palms next to your chest push yourself
up
up squeeze two
back down
squeeze
nice
remember your entire body
should be coming up
in one straight line very good there you
go
give me ten more okay
you got this
back down
control yourself as you come down don't
just collapse
up
squeeze nice
six more
squeeze your back
feel your legs
six more
ah
last five up squeeze your legs for two
counts
last few more
squeeze push up
three more
last two
and one last one
let's go up
squeeze push yourself back up and up
okay
very very well done
now
time for a short break for your upper
body let's get back down and work on
your lower body okay single leg lunge
all right if you find that this is too
challenging you can always place your
leg onto your table or a chair if you
need to okay so
left leg up
work on your right thighs let's go down
bend your knee
up
and squeeze
tap down
and squeeze
only 15 okay
the trick here is to find one focal
point and just focus
on that spot
very good
up
last ten more
bend your knee
breathe out as you come up
breathe in
as you lower yourself down
tap if you need to
good last five more
find your balance
last three more
down
up
down
up and last one more
squeeze
very very good
good job okay change side
now on our left leg okay
so
same thing before you start and get your
car
really and get your car throughout
consciously suck your belly in
and let's go tap down
and back up
good
tap down
back up again for an easy option
tap your feet down
bring it back
up
and tap your feet down okay
down
and tap good ten more let's go
one
lower yourself bend your knee don't rush
through the workout
good
lower and very good the slower you do
this workout the more you will feel your
glutes working
let's get back down
up whoa last five more okay
one
two
three
last two more go low
four
one more find your balance
and
up
okay now let's get into a bridge pose
all right so
bring your body down
again heels together
okay bring your glutes up
squeezing your glutes for two counts at
the top place your palms down and let's
go for 15 okay
tap
up
three
nice
four
five
let's bring up the speed slightly one
two
three as high as again four imagine
there's a string pull your belly button
five
six
seven
eight squeeze
nine
and last
ten
very good okay
now lower body time for a short break
moving on to our upper body okay dolphin
push-up
by now you should know
whether you hit or love this workout
okay so let's get into a low plank
position
all right remember again throughout the
entire workout i'm going to engage your
core so tighten your core
pipe your butt up
back down
and up okay look in between your legs
nice three
very good
four push it up
feel the working triceps your shoulders
five
six
very good halfway there
breathe out as you come up
very good okay really
engage your car hold it for one count
and come
right back down
okay last five more
one
two push it
three
control
four last one more
control
and
five all right drop onto your knees
take a short break get into a child
first
and we have one final workout okay it's
going to be plank up down
all right
ready last final workout and you are
done with two sets let's go up and down
that's one
and that's two okay avoid moving your
hips side to side
do not do this this is wrong okay
this workout is about working on your
upper body as well as a core strength
good
very good you have eight more
let's go
spread your fingers apart
if you want more balance last five more
down
up
last three more
last two more
and
take a shot break okay
two sets down
two more to go ten reps and five reps
okay
take a short break
so you have completed 20 reps 15 reps
and this round is going to be only 10
reps you know all the workouts by now so
give me your best effort start in a low
squat let's go for lateral squat walk
left and right
two
good
three
go low
four do not come up right now
five
six
seven
eight
last two more nine go lower
ten
very good okay
lunch to curtsy okay only ten
ready let's go lunge
and curtsy
good
so remember open up your chest
look straight ahead three
through the burn five
halfway there
six doing a good job
seven
eight take a white lunch okay
nine cross
and ten cross
good job okay left side
all right
ready
let's go take your right step back
and cross
step
and cross
okay when you get into a lunge you're
working on your quads and when you get
into curtsy you're working more
on your glutes as well as your outer
thighs
last five
four
three
two
last one more
one
and back up
okay your favorite push-ups
narrow to wide push-up never push up
we'll be working on our triceps white is
for our chest
alright
let's go down
explode and wide
good
as low as you can try to get your chest
towards the floor
you have two more one narrow
one wide
wide
and back up okay superman
to plank
okay keep up with me short breaks right
now squeeze
and push yourself back up
good reach forward
squeeze
and up very good
nice remember to lift your chest off the
floor your hips off the floor
and push yourself back up
halfway there
last five more
squeeze
up
over one
up
three more
breathe out as you come up
all your energy and breathe out
very good
last one more squeeze and
out
good job
let's get straight back up
back to our lower body single leg lunge
okay
starting on our right side
find your balance let's go down and tap
two
very good squeeze right at the top
squeeze three
back down
four squeeze
straightening legs five
last five more
six good
seven
last three more
eight
nine one more
down
and up
very good okay shake it out
change side all right
left leg now okay
so same thing bend your knee lower
yourself down and up
let's go
two
squeeze
three
four slow it down
five
very good
halfway there
six
plus four more
breathe out as you come up okay
so breathe in
and breathe
out
last two more bend
last one more
slow it down
and up okay
you know the next workout
let's lie down onto the mat
it's going to be a heel touch glued
bridge okay spread your legs
and up one
two gentle tap
three squeeze
four
five very good
six push your knees out
seven
eight
last one more and you wanna hold it
right at the top hold it one
two
three four
and five
okay back down
straight into our upper body
dwarfing push up okay so get into a low
plank position if this is too tough you
can get into a high plank
and pike your butt up alright this is a
easier alternative if not get into a low
plank and give me 10. pike it up
keep your elbows pointed
back okay do not spread your elbows out
three
good
and gaze gently
on the floor and in between
your legs
last five more
one
two remember pointing your elbows back
three pumps on the floor
four last one more
five okay
all right
are we ready for the final workout plank
up down only ten reps
all right let's go low plank up one
two
good
three
strong car four
five good
and again breathe out
as you come up okay
last three more
breathe out
last one more breathe out
and
you are done for round number three
short break and
the final circuit only five repetitions
you got this okay
all right this is your final set you
have made it all the way to this round
okay only five repetitions
let's do it let's go
lateral squat walk one
two very good easy three i'm sure you're
looking forward to this four last one
and five okay
lunge to curtsy okay only five this is a
killer workout i love this workout
one
two very good go low tap your knee onto
the floor
last two more tap let's go add more
intensity more
work
tap
and change to the other side left side
right leg back tap
only five okay so go as low as you can
really
give your muscle that good squeeze
last one more
and back
up
narrow to white push up
as you can see i'm taking almost no
break right now let's go one
wide
really go narrow go all the way wide
give me last two more
and
you are done
superman squeeze to plank
ready squeeze
and up
back down
squeeze
push your entire body up
two
squeeze
three last two more team last two more
squeeze
one more
and
up
okay
back to our lower body single leg lunge
okay
let's try not to rest our left foot at
all ready find your balance let's go one
squeeze
slow it down
two squeeze i'm going to really go slow
as you go low
three squeeze good
go slow
four
squeeze last one more
up
and squeeze
okay change side okay left side
let's go
one
final balance
two my life side is always more
challenging
three
squeeze
four
last one more
and
five all right
down into a bridge position
up
ready
down spread your knees one
two hold for two counts
one two good
one two and last
give me ten pulses one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
and ten very good
okay
final
upper body workout
dolphin push up
get into a low plank position
pumps onto the floor
and
pike it up one
down
two
good
three as high as you can pike your butt
up
four
last one more and hold it right at the
top
one two
three
four
five
okay
one final workout okay plank up down
let's go
start in a low plank
push yourself up one
two
three
four
and five
you are
done
very very well done that was a total
body strength training workout 20 reps
15 reps all the way down to five reps
give me a high five okay
be sure to stretch yourself out and do
check out my other workout videos from
explosive heat workouts kickboxing and
even low impact workouts if you enjoyed
this video do give this video a thumbs
up share this video on and stay home
stay safe and stay active i will see you
in my next workout session all the best